how many people in this audience just
curious believe in the idea that the way
you think has some effect on your life
just curious so you believe on some
level that your thoughts have an effect
on your life so you think 60 to 70,000
thoughts in one day 90% of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before so what is the likelihood of
something happening different in your
life if 90% of those thoughts conscious
or unconscious are the same thoughts as
the day before because the same thoughts
will always lead to the same choices the
same choices will lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors will create
the same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same emotions
and those same emotions drive your very
same thoughts and your biology your
neuros circuitry your neurochemistry
your hormones and even your genetic
expression is equal to how you think how
you act and how you feel and how you
think how you act and how you feel is
called your personality and your
personality creates your personal
reality so then if you want to create a
new personal reality a new life then
you're going to have to start changing
your personality hey it's s Carl Michael
and I make these videos because I need
them because I don't always wake up and
feel motivated to go take on the day and
the thing that saves me that helps me
every day is being around people who are
thinking bigger who are changing the
world and it gives me a little more
inspiration to go after my mission and
so I hope this video helps you go up to
yours today too so today let's learn the
real Law of Attraction Secrets
enjoy secret number two is vibrate on a
higher frequency with Gabby Bernstein we
are just beings of energy we're a free
flowing energy field and that energy
is constantly in a vibrational frequency
and it's either vibrating with the
cosmos vibrating with the universe
vibrating whatever you want to whatever
language you use you know the Angelic
realm The Vortex as of course Miracles
would say the Kingdom of Heaven you know
your your in is on whatever you say
right you're vibing with the cosmos
you're in a good high Vibe joint when
we're in the vibration of the cosmos
we're in the flow of the universe right
so this is an everpresent supporting
presence of love God God to me is the
everpresent
supporting presence of Love That
presence of love that is within us that
is us that's in this Crystal that's why
it's sitting next to me that's in my
iPad that's in my book that's in my
water that's in the chair that's in
every single person in this room there
is nothing else here except for energy
nothing else is here we just thought we
were these bodies I know I told you I
was going to get headyy CU I'm 34 now so
here we go but but the truth is this is
why I've been teaching all along I've
just been disguising it I'm just smiling
at my course of Miracles student friend
in the back over there saying mhm you
know what I'm talking about so so here's
the deal we're just an energy field and
as we all as beings of evolution think
more thoughts those thoughts become
nuclear bombs and those thoughts
become Walmart and those thoughts become
makeup Miracles now or those thoughts
become you know the vision of ABC Carpet
in home or those thoughts become you
know the the the the world that we live
in politics and they become war and they
become violence and they become Civil
War and they become babies those
thoughts create form and so the thoughts
that we have are creating the energy
field they're affecting the energy field
all right you guys know this you're all
metaphysicians but let's just reinforce
it whatever thought you were having is
affecting the form on some
level and and you know the course says
there's only one of us here so back to
that point of there's only one of us
here this just this energy field so
whatever energy we bring to any
situation whether we're we could be
saying all the right words but the
energy that we're bringing is leaving
either a high vibration or a low
vibration and then whatever it's leaving
it's attracting so when we're elevated
into the high vibration that's when we
are a magnet to
receive what is that likeness when we're
elev when we're lowering to the low
vibration because we're in the worry or
we're in the fear or we're in the
judgment or the attack or the separation
or the littleness we're in that
low-level vibration which what does that
attract lowlevel
experiences so your experiences are a
direct reflection of your thoughts and
the form that your thoughts create which
is your energy and we can we can change
that energy field with our thoughts and
with our physical presence right
sometimes we can think our way out and
sometimes we can move our way out and
sometimes we can breathe our way out
there's a lot of ways of tuning back in
which we're going to get get to in
throughout this entire talk but
everyone's with me that we are Just
Energy yeah you got that you're a force
field of energy let's just do a little
exercise everybody rub the palms of your
hands
together rub rub rub rub rub rub rub rub
rub rub rub rub rub rub rub rub rub rub
rub rub create that
friction eyes
closed separate your
hands and then allow them to float back
towards each
other and don't actually you're not
really moving them just feel the
vibration of the energy within your
palms eyes
closed maybe they're moving on their
own maybe you don't feel it at all but
that's wherever you
are and just take a deep breath in and
release
and uh open your eyes what did you
feel
magnetic vibrating
warmth a
pulse yeah energy right that was just an
example of how you can just feel your
energy right or you do ego Eradicator
and you feel a Vibra you start to
vibrate right um I I I put on Instagram
one of the lessons in the book is called
take a light bath I I whenever I'm on
the road or even like yesterday when I
had really bad PMS sorry to the men the
three men in the room
um Harold okay um I literally just like
said hi to all four of them um so um
when you have that experience um what
happened for me was I was just in such a
low Vibe I lied down on the floor and I
Envision this light pouring over me and
I'd like to give you a visceral
experience of this it's going to be a
very experiential Workshop okay because
you know we can talk about energy but
unless we feel what the vibrational
frequency of the energy is to us we will
not be able to walk away saying I am a
magnet for miracles people you
know otherwise you're just going to be
in that place we like yeah yeah totally
like I totally believe in the Law of
Attraction and like I can totally
attract what I believe in no I I don't
really give a what you say and
that's the last time I'm cursing
I don't care what you say I care what
how you
be there's nothing funny about that I
care how you be I care how you be and
and and Yogi budon said um if your
presence isn't working your word will
never
work if your presence doesn't work your
word will never work your word means
nothing without your presence secret
number three is instruct your
subconscious mind with Wayne Dyer the
third of these principles is the
principle of I call it assuming the
feeling of the wish fulfilled you must
be able to uh feel it because every time
that you feel something within your body
you give a instruction to your
subconscious mind and your subconscious
mind is the part of you where you do all
of your living you want to redo your
subconscious mind now I jotted down for
my last the last principle I have five
minutes left
and it's
[Music]
um this is uh from The Book of
Job now
tonight I'm going to give you guys such
a
gift tonight and every night for the
rest of your life I want you to take the
last 5 minutes before you go off to
sleep and realize that you are about to
program your subconscious mind all right
your subconscious mind is most at home
when you are unconscious when you are
asleep if you spend the last 5 minutes
of your day which so many people do
reviewing all of the things that you
don't like and all the things that
didn't work out and how terrible you
feel and who abused you and who was mean
to you and who said this and they did
this and you're constantly doing this
kind of thing with your mind
then you are programming your
subconscious mind that when you awaken
CU you're now about to marinate for the
next 8 hours in your subconscious mind
and then when you awaken you will rejoin
the
universal subconscious mind the mind of
God from which we all originate we're
all just individualized Personal
Expressions of that one thing that we
call the da or God or Divine mind or
soul or Spirit but the Dow that can be
named is not the
da so you want to be real careful about
how you program your subconscious mind
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there secret number four is be on the
happiness frequency with Ronda burn let
me talk about happiness and
manifestation um because that it's
really really interesting in in the
secret book um I say that the shortcut
to anything and everything is to be
happy first and the reason for that is
that on the frequency of
Happiness um is everything that you want
that's going to make you happy because
whatever it is that you want to manifest
or to not manifest you want it because
you'll be happier for the having of it
or for the not having of it and so
that's why everything that we all want
is on the frequency of happiness and so
if you are happy first happy now then
what happens is it's really really easy
to manifest in fact everything is on
that frequency so while you're on that
frequency everything can come in that
you really really want so it's it's
happiness and manifestation they're just
one they they belong together
um so I've made some notes here and I
want to make sure that I tell you
everything because I want you to be so
empowered after this chat together um
okay so in The Greatest Secret I explain
happiness I go into a lot more detail
about happiness in fact there's a whole
chapter on happiness and and why I talk
about it a lot in the greater secret is
because happiness is your true nature
it's not actually something that you
have it's something that you are and so
the infinite being that you are is
happiness I mean you you know you could
say that our name is happiness and that
would not be wrong because so any time
that you've been happy in your life like
um no matter what it was where you've
just felt happy you were getting a tiny
glimpse of the infinite being that you
are
are and so just imagine when you are
living from the place of the infinite
being that you are how blissfully happy
you would be all of the time and if you
were blissfully happy all of the time
that means you have zero
resistance which means everything
manifests so do you see how beautiful
beautifully they're all kind of tied in
together happiness manifestation and the
infinite being that you are now the
infinite being is not the person okay
the person is something you're having a
lot of fun an adventure experiencing
maybe it's an adventure maybe it's fun
um that's that's what that's an
experience that you're having but it's
not who you are and who you are is the
infinite being and who you are can
manifest anything because you are the
one and only Power in the universe and
when we're coming from the perspective
of a person with all of our wound up
beliefs and everything that we've taken
on it's kind of challenging to realize
that you are the infinite being that is
all the power in the universe but you
are even if you find it hard to believe
you still are so uh let's have a
look I'm really good at just I do all
these notes but then when I take a look
then when I take a look I've told you
everything so
uh oh yes you know one of the things
uh is when you're really happy
manifestation happens so so fast like
instantaneously and you know you've seen
that happen when when there's
manifestations that people call Miracles
that's just a that's just an
instantaneous manifestation that
happened really fast and you know the
person who has a miracle happened either
has has actually no resistance and has
total total faith that it's going to
happen and and then we see what's called
a miracle so they could have total faith
in God for example but it's their faith
that causes them to let go of all
resistance and then when you let go of
all
resistance manifestation is immediate so
the other thing I want you to know is
this when you are truly truly happy any
negativity that is negative beliefs
beliefs that don't serve you any
negativity that's in your body that
we've kind of suppressed down from
experiences that were challenging while
you are
happy all of that is being
released and um it's like a my teacher
would call it a self cleansing
mechanism so when you're happy and also
you know there's something else that I'd
like you to just as an experiment maybe
do is when you're really happy just
check out your thoughts because you
don't have many thoughts when you're
really really happy and all of those
thoughts are happy thoughts because
you're on the happiness frequency so
what's on the happiness frequency only
happiness thoughts right secret number
five is improve your focus with Marissa
Pier so the Law of Attraction if you
simplify it says whatever you focus on
you can get more focus on what you want
and you'll get more of it and that is
actually true whatever you focus on you
move towards which is why it is so
important to focus on what you want and
do not focus on what you don't want
after all if you were having an
injection in your arm and you look at it
and think about it it's more painful
than if you read a message on your phone
and take your attention elsewhere so I
absolutely believe and science has
proven that when you focus on something
you go towards it but the thing I think
lets people down in the law of
attraction is that it doesn't ever talk
about application it kind of says you
want the best partner in the world focus
on it think about it imagine they're
there and they will turn up and I'm like
well not really if you never leave the
couch how are they going to turn up you
see if I want a new home I can think
about the home I want I can imagine but
I also know I've got to go and look at
it I've got to go onto websites and look
at homes and then go and view that home
if I wanted a new job I can think about
the new job imagine the new job and
believe I can manifest it but I also
need to apply for that new job go for
interviews put myself out there and if
you want an amazing relationship here
here is how the Law of Attraction works
it makes you think about what you want
it makes you believe that you are worth
what you want but it misses out
something very important you must
actually go out there put yourself in
front of the kind of person you want to
be with so the first step is to think
about what you really want the kind of
person you want what qualities would
they have but then there's a second
thing you must do okay I've worked out
what I want but what kind of person does
what I want want maybe I'm going to have
to do some work on myself if I want a
really fit person that's into working
out and super healthy I better at least
become healthy and enjoy that too if I
want someone who is deeply intellectual
maybe I should start reading more
intellectual books too you don't have to
change
yourself but you may have to do
something cuz women especially very good
at this is what what I want and meant to
I want this that's what I want but then
you got to think about what does what
you want want when you've done that I
know what I want I know what that person
wants back I believe I'm worthy of that
person now you have to put yourself in
front of those people you have to go
where they are if you believe you're
worthy of love and then go to somewhere
where the kind of person you want to be
with is you'll probably end up with that
person if you believe you're worthy of
love and you don't put yourself in front
of that person it just won't work and I
know this I've met so many women who go
yeah I'm really ready for a great guy
what do you do in your spare time I go
to yoger I go to a woman's B club and I
hang out with my girlfriends well that's
lovely but You' just said you want a
great guy you got to leave the yoga room
and go to the gym go to the weight room
even if you don't want to do weights cuz
you got to put yourself in front of the
kind of guy you want to be with so
forget about yoga and leave the woman's
book club and find a book club where men
are and I find men do the same thing
what do you want I want a really fit
girl are there any in the wait room no
then go to yoga go to Pilates put
yourself in front of the kind of person
you want while knowing with
unshakeable conviction with abs absolute
certainty you are worth it so the law of
attraction is great at making you
believe something one of the things I
noticed on Law of Attraction is someone
who had cancer and she was saying on
there I kept saying thank you for my
healing thank you for my healing thank
you for my healing believing I was
already healed and I think that's
wonderful but there is a second step you
need to read some books on what you can
do to help your body fight cancer you
need to take certain supplements there
are so many things you can do
supplements vitamins
lifestyle
meditation taking all the parabens out
of your products not sleeping with your
mobile phone under your pillow so if you
believe that you can heal yourself and
add into that mix certain things that
certainly help you heal yourself you are
more likely to heal yourself and let's
imagine you want the career of your
dreams or maybe you want to start your
own business and that's all good and you
can use the law of attraction to
visualize the career of your dreams to
visualize someone funding your business
setting up your startup and it's a great
visualization you can use vision boards
you can use meditation you can use so
many things to excite your imagination
to fire off those neurons that go hey I
can do this but you still
have to take action the best plan in the
world may not work if you don't work too
and secret number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
send positive energy out with Bob
Proctor I think Emerson said the law of
caus and effect was the law of laws that
says Action Reaction or equ equal and
opposite so whatever thought you send
out that's what's coming back as a
matter of fact you send good energy out
you'll take on an equal amount of like
energy simultaneously with sending it
out that's how it
works you see as the energy flows in it
turns into whatever we decided it'll
turn into and if we're thinking good
thoughts then automatically the energy
coming in becomes good
thoughts what you send out you take on
the energy you send you receive you take
on an equal amount of like energy
simultaneously with sending it
out so you your thoughts then set up
your feelings we said that attitude is
thoughts feelings and actions the
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration you're in it's not just on a
conscious level you're thinking now
you've internalized those thoughts so
you put your entire being mind body into
a vibration well if that's the vibration
you're in that's the vibration you're
sending out that's what the universe is
going to send back Action Reaction are
equal and opposite that is an absolute
law of the universe as I already said
Emerson said it is the law of
laws and then the feeling that we're
experienc is not only a vibration we're
sending out we're sending it out with
and through this instrument we're living
in our body and so the vibration them
dictates how we
act so our thoughts our feelings and our
actions being expressed it's a two-edged
sword whatever we send out the universe
sends right back you see you see a
person with a bad attitude they
generally have a good reason for have a
bad attitude they keep thinking of all
those new reasons why because they're
sending them out they're coming right
back at them what we've got to do is
stop right in our tracks if things
aren't going right and say hold on a
minute if I don't like what's coming to
me I've got to understand I've ordered
it it's being delivered right on
schedule because that's the way the law
Works what we put out comes back I think
I'm going to stop right now and start
sending good thoughts good feelings good
actions towards everyone and everything
I do I know there's something in you
it's an old Paradigm probably saying
that's not being realistic who the hell
wants to be realistic let's be
successful let's have a great attitude
let's have the universe shower us with
good and you know something we can all
we have to do is here with the universe
gives it right back just like
that that's attitude a double-edged
sword what you put up baby you're going
to get it
back most people never manifest their
ideas because you don't trust your ideas
that bold idea that came to you that
made sense to you in the moment the next
day feels too bold too crazy too insane
too not for someone like you I believe
that the decisions that come to you when
you're feeling bold are actually the
right ones for you and you have to take
immediate action on because otherwise
your head gets in the way and talks you
down from doing the things that you
should be doing so right now I'm in the
process of looking for a creative
director for my business someone to look
at all my content suggest ways to make
it better to to be focused on The
Branding and opportunities for me and
this was a suggestion from Mark drer
friend of the channel longtime personal
friend of mine as well he helped film my
very first video he's the reason why I
did top 10 moves to success long story
with Mark and he said Evan you need a
creative director for your business
creative director or brand manager or
CEO somebody to be in charge of all the
creative decisions and getting me out on
the stages that they need to be out on
so how do we make these videos better
that's that person's role and so in my
head when he first said it I'm I'm a
little afraid I'm scared like how do I
find this person I need to Vibe well
with them I don't I can't just bring
anybody into that role I'm I'm a pretty
weird duck and so this has to be a good
you know long-term fit for me how much
this person going to cost how do I fit
into my cost structure right now with my
business how we going to deal with
conflict so it's all of the negativity
all of the things that are reasons why
it's not going to work and so inste need
to focus on this is a bold idea and I
need to at least explore it I need to
try it I need to play it out maybe it
works maybe it doesn't but teaching
yourself teaching myself that I do bold
things I do scary things I do difficult
things and being scared is not a good
enough reason for not to take action and
so those ideas that come to you trust
trust that they came to you for a reason
if it came to you and you're thinking
about it and you feel bold like man I
would love to go off and do that the
best thing you can do it just start
going off and doing that because what's
going to happen is you're going to plan
plan plan plan plan you're going to
spend all your best energies just stuck
in planning mode instead of actually
going out and taking action you're going
to tell your friends about it they're
going to tell you it's a stupid idea
you're going to sleep on it you're going
to wake up and tell yourself it's a
stupid idea and then what happens is no
momentum the biggest thing that is
missing from your
life is momentum ena's happy you's
smiling she's next to me filming that's
all that's missing you're a genius you
have great ideas great genius Amazing
Ideas you're just missing
momentum because once you get the idea
you sit on it and then you tell yourself
why you can't do it instead of going off
and proving to yourself that you can so
how do you find the ideas and then how
do you take action on them I'm going to
give you a three-step process step
number one is go for a walk have a
shower do whatever the thing is that
makes you feel energized
creative and in the zone right if you're
constantly just in front of your phone
and stressed out all day long you're not
going to come up with creative ideas so
where do you get creative ideas I get
creative ideas when I'm driving I get
creative ideas when I'm in the shower I
get creative ideas when I'm walking I
don't really meditate so I don't get
ideas when I'm doing that but it's it's
time when there's nothing scheduled and
so do you have enough time during your
week or during your day that is open
that you allow yourself to think and be
creative for a lot of people watching
this you probably do you probably have
some moments in your calendar that are
dedicated to at least having a shower
hope hopefully hopefully you have
showers on regular basis right so you're
coming up with ideas right so whatever
that thing is that lets you come up with
ideas do more of it right if you get
great ideas in the shower maybe instead
of a 5 minute shower you take a 15minute
shower maybe you get some more ideas
coming to you right you want to you want
to spend more time doing the work that
generates creativity for you that's step
number one step number two is don't
judge the ideas that come to you this is
where so many people fall down you get
an idea and then you judge it and you
say I can't do that I'm not good enough
I don't have the money I don't have the
connections I didn't go to school for
that I'm not tall enough I'm not pretty
enough I'm not smart enough whatever
people like me don't do this thing all
these ideas why you can't win you're
telling yourself why you can't win
before you've even started don't judge
the idea trust that the idea came to you
for a reason so if I'm thinking about
somebody in the shower somebody that
maybe I met yesterday or somebody that I
haven't talked to in 3 years why am I
thinking about that person oh I don't
know
B Italians have this expression they go
b means I don't know B so I trust the
idea came for a reason that idea is
flowing through me for a reason and I
got to do something about it and so
whenever I'm thinking about somebody in
the shower the next thing is I get out
of the shower and I'll email that person
right away and I'll always make it
awkward and say hey I was thinking about
you in the shower today and then tell
them what the story was and it's never
backfired on me it's never backfired on
me sometimes it leads to some great
opportunity and sometimes it goes
nowhere but you get the idea you do
something get the idea you do something
stop judging the idea stop telling
yourself why you can't do it and then
step number three is take immediate
action and build momentum again the
biggest thing that you're just missing
is momentum you're a genius you're an
amazing entrepreneur you've got tons of
potential Sarah Blakeley had this idea
to create Spanx and it made her
billionaire when everybody thought she
was crazy right I'm sure you have ideas
like that too what's the difference
between you and her momentum she did
more she started she took the no she
took the rejection she took the fears
and she said I'm going to give it my
shot you need to build immediate
momentum as soon as you get that idea
whether it's in the shower on the walk
on the drive whatever it is as soon as
you get that it you're not allowed to
leave that moment that moment of Courage
that moment of boldness that moment of
feeling Unstoppable that moment of like
I can do this when you're feeling that
moment you're not allowed to leave it
without having done something immediate
action every single time and sometimes
that leads to something great and maybe
the momentum falls off the next day
that's okay but in the moment
you have to take immediate action no
more excuses stop let yourself off the
hook stop telling yourself that you suck
and you can't do it and go show yourself
that you can first of all every time we
have a thought we make a chemical and
and if you have uh an unlimited thought
you will feel unlimited and if you have
a a self-depreciating thought you'll
feel unworthy and your brain
instantaneously fires circuits that
signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical Messengers
that hormonal centers and when we get
that arousal from the thought that we
think uh those thoughts sometimes weaken
the response weakens the physical body
so turns out that the emotions that are
created from the thoughts are the
signaling mechanisms of the body
thoughts are the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel uh
creates our state of being so it turns
out that the thought thoughts based in
the stress hormones based in survival
those are the thoughts that begin to
push the genetic buttons that create
disease in other words a person wakes up
in the morning and the brain is a record
of the past the first thing they do when
they wake up in the morning is they
start thinking about their problems and
those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects uh
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right now every one of those problems
has an emotion associated with them
because we've experienced them so the
moment you remember your problems now
you feel unhappy now you feel anxious
now you feel fear so the moment we feel
those emotions it takes a thought and a
feeling a memory or an image and an
emotion a stimulus and a response and we
start conditioning the body emotionally
into the past now the body is so
objective that it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience that's creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition so if the environment signals
the Gene and that's the truth and the
end product of an experiences in the
environment is an
emotion we're signaling the same genes
and genes make proteins and if you keep
signaling the same genes you start
downregulating the Gene and make cheaper
proteins and the body begins to break
down now that's an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is uh the
brain checks in with the body and says
yeah you're feeling pretty miserable
you're suffering and we tend to generate
more thoughts equal to the feeling that
we have and so then we get caught in
this Loop of thinking and feeling so if
we can't think
greater than how we feel our feelings
have become the means of thinking than
we're thinking in the past right and so
we call that the familiar past and then
a person gets going in the day and they
start thinking oh I got to see this
person I got to go to that meeting I
hate doing this and now they get in
their routine and a habit is a redundant
set of automatic unconscious thoughts
behaviors and emotions that's acquired
through repetition a habit is when
you've done something so many times that
the body now knows how to do it better
than the mind so now the person running
through the same routine every single
day is on autopilot and their body is
now dragging them into a predictable
future based on what they did in the
past and they've lost their free will to
a set of programs right so now you have
the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are known so
the only place then reasonably where the
unknown exists is The Sweet Spot of the
generous present moment that is when the
body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts people
start becoming more judgmental they
start becoming more impatient they start
becoming more entitled uh they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted of energy because it's
believing that it's living in an
emergency situation and in emergency you
tap all of the body body's resources for
some threat whether it's real or
imagined and so then when you're
releasing all of these chemicals we are
literally drawing the body's life force
and turning it into chemistry and so for
the short term that's cool but the
arousal that's created from those stress
hormones is a rush of energy and so then
people use the problems and the
conditions in their life to reaffirm
their conditioning or their addiction to
that emotion and in a sense they become
addicted to the life they don't even
like and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay I'm not
going to say I can't I'm not going to
judge another person I'm not going to
blame I'm not going to complain I'm not
going to make excuses I'm not going to
be a victim I'm not going to talk trash
about anybody I'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours then the body saying
you're out of schedule you normally at
8:00 in the morning you're get in
traffic and you're angry then at 11:00
you check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
Mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known so the
body starts influencing the mind and it
says you know come on this is a good
time to judge that come on this is a
good time to suffer it's your ex's fault
it's it's your it's the government's
fault it's uh you know it's the weather
what the news whatever it is and if we
accept believe and surrender to that
thought without analyzing it it slips by
and it begins to program the autonomic
nervous system to make those Pharmacy of
chemicals and so that's when the person
makes the same Choice does the same
thing creates the same experience just
for that familiar feeling okay I'll
complain just so I can feel suffering
then they'd rather be unhappy than step
into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process first of all is not making
the same Choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff you got to stay
conscious and not go unconscious and it
turns out that 95% of the time we're
unconscious so if you're going to stay
conscious then there's an element that
also requires a certain amount of
awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking are slipping by their
awareness unnoticed because they're
hardwired in their brain because they've
been saying I can't it's too hard my
life will never change it's someone
else's fault those thoughts have
consequences in the body so then if a
person then becomes conscious of those
unconscious thoughts becomes aware of
how they speak and how they act and they
notice how they're feeling they no
longer the program they're the
Consciousness outside the program and
that's the first step to change
so there there when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and your tweeting
and your instagramming and Facebook and
whatever people do you're distracted by
that feeling but I now know that if you
take a person and you say Okay close
your eyes sit in the in the Silence of
any external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay I'm going to feed you you can check
your cell phone you can shower you can
have your coffee but when I say and so
then Here Comes The Challenge right so
and and then if you say then you're not
going to live in The Familiar F A
Familiar past or predictable future
you're not going to think about how long
you've been meditating what you got to
do you you
Labor uh for that present
moment people think when they do this
that they're doing something wrong
because there's such discomfort that
comes with it but they're in the unknown
they're actually doing it right people
say I think I'm meditating wrong I
always say oh no no no you're doing it
right because when you notice that your
body wants to get up and check your cell
phone or have a cup of coffee and you
become aware that it's on autopilot and
wants to do that and you say uh-uh come
on over here and you return it back to
the present moment you're executing a
will now that's greater than the program
and if the person's wants to just get
angry while they're sitting there
there's an arousal and they notice the
body is amping up and revving up and
they settle it back down now they're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this and it's tedious in the
beginning at first because David is
fighting Goliath but if you keep
practicing it just like training an
animal sooner or later the body
acquiesces sooner or later the body is
trained to a new mind and when that
happens there's a liberation of energy
the body goes from particle to wave from
matter to energy and there goes that
emotion literally liberated from the
body as energy so the person who has the
strong emotion to some circumstance in
their life and they're they're working
and lowering the volume of that emotion
the more they lower the volume of that
emotion the more they're going to take
their attention off that person in
problem and they're going to take their
power back there's going to be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self
so I think you know it's not like
thinking positively that's not the
message it's it's overcoming overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently and
they start feeling differently they're a
new personality and they they start
seeing those synchronicities and
serendipities
now Crossing that River of
change the creative process now gets
exciting because what thoughts do you
want to fire and wire in your brain what
kind of attention and intention the
biggest message I want to get across
when it comes to the law of attraction
is that it requires effort it requires
some type of action that's why in the
word attraction you see action in the
word you don't just get to write down
something on a piece of paper or have a
vision board or you know map something
out or cut out photos and and look at it
in front of you every single day or
write down things on a piece of paper
and think hard about it for a few
minutes and then expect everything in
your life to change and to be this
magnet of opportunities to have everyone
that you want in your life attracted to
you money good health opportunities with
your career it's not going to happen
overnight like that and I wish it did
but it's not that easy so there are some
beliefs and actions that we need to take
place in order for it to work and that's
what we're going to do by diving into
today so the first thing you want to
think about is switching from negativity
to positivity so many people get caught
up in focusing on what they don't want
to happen in their future and I want to
talk about this a little bit towards the
end of this video on how to focus on
some of the negative things that could
happen but really focusing on the
positive for the main part of your life
we'll talk about that towards the end
because this is an important distinction
but they start living almost in constant
fear of what could go wrong and what
won't work out and when we come from
this place of well I don't know if I put
myself out there you know it's not going
to work out and then I'm going to get
made fun of and then people I'm going to
be embarrassed and I'm going to be
stressed and no one's going to love me
and then we go in this rabbit hole and
this kind of cycle of fear and anxiety
and that is not how you attract good
things in your life you can't start from
your way of being of negativity and fear
and expect to attract beautiful things
in your life so we we need to eliminate
the negative selft talk and an
environment that's easy to get stuck in
sometimes can be the negative selft talk
and there's so much negativity in the
world and if you don't actively work to
shift your focus to shift your thoughts
and your mind that negativity will will
consume you and that's where the Law of
Attraction comes in now for me it's
about focusing Less on what I don't want
to happen in the future and actually
focus on what I do want and again I
think a lot of people focus on what they
don't want too much and you start to
attract the things you're thinking about
I don't want this I don't want that
those things start to come to you you
start to see them it's like the ex old
example of someone says you know don't
think of a pink elephant you start to
see it and you start to imagine it if
you say well I don't want to be poor you
start to feel it and you start to
imagine it and you start to have anxiety
around it so you want to really think
about the positive things in your life
you want to think about what do I want
to attract who do I want to become what
do I want to overcome so for example if
you're becoming a negative person you're
more likely to attract more negative
people rather than positive ones because
positive people won't want to be around
you you know negativity keeps company
and so does positivity when you start to
see other positive people that are like
you you say I want to hang out with
those people those people are going to
continue to lift me up I can lift them
up it's a good cycle but the negative
stuff you start to attract when you talk
about gossip and you talk about bad news
and you talk about comparison and
judgment and anxiety and stress that
feeds in a community of other people
that speak in the same language so you
want to shift your language and start
thinking more positively and if you feel
like you aren't deserving of a loving
relationship a loving partner you're
most likely going to attract the wrong
type of people in your life and if
you're focusing on how much money you
don't have in your life right now or how
your business could fail you're not
going to be able to focus your energy on
the right clients or the products that
will take your business to the next
level or the skills you need to develop
to help you grow now your thoughts
dictate your actions and where your
energy goes so you want to be thinking
about what can I do to replace these
negative thoughts the anxiousness or the
fear how can I replace it so my energy
can go in a more positive direction and
again where you put your energy into is
what you
attract so if you're thinking negative
thoughts all day long you're probably to
attract that if you're thinking
gratitude and positive thoughts you'll
start to see that show up differently so
how can we put the Law of Attraction
into practice now let's go back to our
examples and apply a new way of thinking
if you are caught in thinking negatively
about the world and about yourself this
is so important what would change inside
of you if you looked around and you
wrote down five things that you're
grateful for about the world now this
for me is part of the secret to the Law
of Attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that I
should not have attracted because I
didn't have the skills because I didn't
have the tools because I didn't have the
education because I didn't have the
money because I didn't have have the
resources so many things that I
shouldn't have attracted but because I
had the foundation of
gratitude passion Joy curiosity those
things started to come to me and they
can come to you as well if you come from
that place of gratitude as your
foundation so you want to think about
what are these things that are important
to me in my life you know it can be
simple things it could be like this cup
of coffee that I have right now it can
be that I have a roof over my head that
I've got quality friends that I'm
healthy you know that I'm walking in
nature today it doesn't have to be some
grandiose thing that's happened to you
to be grateful for I'm so grateful for
these little present moments with people
that I care about to spend an hour on
the beach to go for a walk with a friend
to have a good conversation with someone
and talk about something that I'm going
through for me that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something something I embed in
my daily life when I wake up I think
about what I'm grateful for when I go to
sleep I I think about and reflect on the
things I'm grateful for from that day
and it's just my way of being for as
much as I can now I'm not perfect I make
mistakes and there's times I'm negative
but it's something that I try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough that
you don't deserve success what if you
looked in the mirror on a daily basis I
dare you to look in the mirror on a
daily basis and say I am enough and I do
deserve the results that I want to
create in my life because I show up
because I'm consistent because I work
hard because I care about my work if you
looked in the mirror and you did this
consistently for 30 days and you
actually use the word action in
attraction and you put it into practice
on a daily basis towards that growth I'd
be amazed to see what you attract and
what you manifest in your life or if you
felt like you weren't deserving of a
loving partner and just kept focusing on
the wrong people what if you said you
know what I am deserving of a loving
partner because I care deeply about
those around me and I'm worthy of
feeling deeply cared about myself and
what if you started to change your
thoughts and behaviors around yourself
and say I'm not going to keep doing the
things that I've always done I'm going
to start showing up differently and love
myself and not needing someone else to
love me who maybe isn't in the right
mindset and start distancing yourself
from those typical patterns that you've
had in the past and love yourself first
and see what you attract from that
loving grateful place with yourself or
if you are in a tough Financial spot
maybe you're struggling financially and
you've been trying to start a business
or a side hustle I've been there I know
what this feels like it's not fun for a
long time I was living on my sister's
couch and I didn't have much money it
was really stressful I remember this
feeling of being stuck feeling like I
was never going to make any money and
when I was focusing on that feeling of
I'm never going to make this money I
feel stuck I feel trapped when's this
going to happen feeling this anxiousness
this stress around it it was really
impossible for me to think of creative
ideas it was impossible for me to take
action because I was living in the
stress as opposed to the gratitude for
what I was having in that moment I
should have been focusing on you know
what my sister is allowing me to stay
here for free so I have some time to
learn a new skill I made $100 this day I
should be grateful for that not a
focusing on what I'm lacking or what I
don't have but what I am creating on a
daily basis and I started to ask
different questions around this time
like how can I be of service to other
people how can I add as much value to
someone else or what are my top skill
sets that I can use to my advantage that
no one else has like what do I have I
started writing a list of all these
different skills that I had even when I
didn't think I had many skills I still
wrote down a list of the qualities I
have of the skills from the past that
maybe I could apply to right now now and
when I began asking those types of
questions I started attracting the
people who needed my skill sets and
services and I finally started to make
more money than ever before because I
was thinking about serving others I was
thinking from a positive grateful
standpoint about helping others and
starting a side hustle which turned into
a business instead of thinking
negatively about not having any money or
I'm sleeping on my sister's couch and
why is it taking me so long to create
this and I'll never make anything from
this situation I started focusing on how
can I add value as much value as
possible to this one person in front of
me right now how can I serve them how
can I create for them how can I connect
someone to them that could help them
what can I do to add value and help
someone else achieve their goals because
I think as Zig Ziggler said if you want
to accomplish all of your goals help
other people accomplish their goals and
that's what I started focusing on not
what I'm lacking but how can I give and
how can I add value to other people when
you Focus outward on service you start
to really attract some incredible things
in your life it's unbelievable the
ripple effect the domino effect one
person helping another person how it
comes back around to you the tonian
world is all about the predictable it's
all about predicting a future but the
quantum model of reality is is about
causing an effect the moment you start
feeling abundant and worthy you are
generating wealth the moment you're
empowered and feel it you're beginning
to step towards your success the moment
you start feeling whole your Healing
Begins and when you love yourself and
you love all of life you'll create an
equal and now you're causing an effect
and I think that's the the difference
between living as a victim in your world
saying I am this way because of this
person or that thing or this experience
they made me think and feel this way
when you switch that around you become a
creator of your world and you start
saying my thinking and my feeling is
changing an outcome in my life and now
that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality how do we then go from that
like mechanistically MH to begin this
visualization process of something
that's empowering it's me in a different
state it's my futural self is it
meditation is it what does that look
like if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future then you're left
with the old memories of the past and
you will be predictable in your
life and if you wake up in the morning
and you're not being defined by a vision
in the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time it's no longer that your
personality is creating your personal
reality now your personal reality is
affecting or creating your personality
your environment is really controlling
how you think and feel unconsciously
because every person every every place
every experience has a neurological
Network in your brain every experience
that you have with every person produces
es and emotion so some people will use
their boss to reaffirm their addiction
to judgment they'll use their enemy to
reaffirm their addiction to hatred
they'll use their friends to reaffirm
their addiction to suffering so now they
need the outer world to feel something
so to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive so then
why is meditation the tool well let's
sit down let's Close Our Eyes let's
disconnect from your outer environment
so if you're seeing less things there's
less stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body
down and tell it to stay like an animal
stay right here I'm going to feed you
when we're done you can get up and check
your emails you can do all your texts
but right now you're going to sit there
and obey me so then when you you do that
properly and you're not eating anything
or smelling anything or tasting anything
you're not up experiencing and feeling
anything you would have to agree with me
that you're being defined by a thought
right so when the body wants to go back
to its emotional
past and you become aware that your
attention is on that emotion and where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy you're siphoning your
energy out of the present moment into
the past and you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment cuz it's saying well
it's 8:00 you normally get upset cuz
you're in traffic around this time and
here you are sitting and we're used to
feeling anger and you're off schedule oh
it's 11:00 and usually check your emails
and judge everybody well the body's
looking for that that predictable
chemical state every time you become
aware that you're doing that and your
body is craving those emotions and you
settle it back down into the present
moment you're telling the body it's no
longer the mind that you're the mind and
and now your will is getting greater
than the program and if you keep doing
this over and over again over and over
again over and over again just like
training a stallion or a dog it's just
going to say I'm going to sit and the
moment that happens when the body is no
longer the mind when it finally
surrenders there's a liberation of
energy we go from particle to wave from
matter to energy and we free ourselves
from the chains of those emotions that
keep us in the in the familiar past and
we've seen
thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
when we're talking about energy there's
the Great Law of Attraction and
vibration when things are on the same
frequency there are in resonance all
right so let's not think of the Law of
Attraction okay as this thing that's
like a magnet that attracts because if
you were to take magnets and put
together you know positive and positive
it actually will repel it's positive and
negative that are in resonance and
attract so when we're thinking about the
law of attraction I want you to skip the
old metaphysical laws that you may have
heard of or explanations you heard of
and I want you to think about resonance
so for example if you ever walked into a
room and not a word has been said and
you know something's wrong and you say
cuz you're feeling the vibration you're
feeling this something is wrong your
intuition is picking up the vibration in
the room and you know something's wrong
and you go hey what's wrong and the
people in the room go oh nothing and you
go no no seriously what's wrong well how
do you know that something is off and
the answer is because this thing called
our body and this thing called our brain
is is energy vibrating at a certain
frequency and so when things things are
not great we're emitting this frequency
that other humans can feel we're picking
it up with our intuitive sensors in our
brain and through our field so when we
think about the law of
attraction we should actually be
thinking about am I in resonance right
okay energy that is on the same
frequency will resonate in attract so if
you want to understand the Law of
Attraction around wealth a relationship
Health money are you in
resonance with that which is already
here see if you're thinking positive but
you're feeling negative if you're
thinking you know I want to double
triple quintuple my income but inside of
you you're thinking that you're not
smart enough not good enough not not
worthy enough then part of you is
vibrating at the here's what I want to
have be attract Etc but if there's
another part of you vibrating at a
different frequency there is no Harmony
there is no resonance there's
chaos because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to learn to activate the live of
Attraction check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I'm going to want to share
threethe with you that I truly believe
that I'm not that law of attraction but
I can tell you images pictures looking
at other possibilities getting examples
of other people doing things is so so
valuable I mean it's